Kim is with us in Louisville Kentucky hi
Kim welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey
thank you for taking my call
sure what's up I have a question I have
two sons and my husband and I made an
agreement with them if they make good
grades through college they were taking
the headed take out student loans that
we would repay their student loans back
for their undergraduate work and they
both just graduated about two weeks ago
and we had paid all of their student
loans off except we have about a year's
worth on each that we still need to pay
it's about what over twenty thousand on
each loan so now that they graduated and
I know in the next six months they're
going to you know need to start paying
on those or we're going to start need to
start paying on those so the question is
one of the things we've been thinking
about is taking out a loan from our 401k
plan to pay at one of those off is that
a good idea or is that not a good idea
let's start with you're not paying it
off you're moving it over to a 401k loan
it's not paid off I mean you just moved
it you change right you change the kind
of debt is all no it's never a good idea
to borrow on a 401k ever here's why okay
the reason people do it is they go oh
I'm paying my self interest I'm gonna
pay four or five six seven percent to
myself isn't that wonderful
no you just unplug good mutual funds
that were paying you ten or twelve while
you pay yourself a lame-o rate and if
you pay yourself money you didn't really
gain anything it was your money you know
no that there's no gain there the second
problem is when you leave your company
and you will leave your company when you
die when you get a better job or when
they fire you one of the three things
will occur when you leave your company
not if the 401k loan is called
do in full you have 60 days to pay it
off if you do not it's considered an
early withdrawal and you get tagged with
penalties of 10% and hit with the your
tax rate as well so no no no what's your
household income
little over 200,000 is there any reason
in the world you can't pay off $40,000
in one year I'm sorry good yeah I think
that would be tough I don't know the
week I'll be tough you make 200 grand 40
out of two and a grand leaves you a
lousy 160 to live on cry me a river well
I mean we have car loans and mortgage
payments and so you guys are making
Twitter here and you're broke have an
extra 40,000 your car loans we have one
car loan yes
what's your stupid car about 30 oh my
god we just bought in about a year ago
okay listen I really can't help you get
out of debt as long as your goal is to
go back in every time you want something
you're gonna have to stop this you
really are I mean you need to get on a
dadgum budget and clean up this mess and
quit buying crap that you don't have the
money to pay for oh my gosh you make
$200,000 a year and you financed a
$30,000 car yeah you need to you guys
need to pay off $70,000 this year you
don't need to go on vacation you need to
stay out of restaurants you need to cut
your freakin lifestyle down and clean up
this mess no you don't need a 401k loan
you make tons of money and you're broke
you have nothing you couldn't even pay
cash for your own car this is awful you
have to get control of this you're gonna
wake up in ten years and cry that I have
made two million dollars and I have
nothing to show for it you've got to
stop this and get control of your budget
so that you guys can pay cash for things
so you can avoid debt which gives you
cash flow to build wealth you gotta do
this so no you don't need a 401k loan
you need to straighten up